hey folks and welcome to another episode
of generation next now this week
we're going to be answering all your
questions about the playstation 5.
it's it's huge uh because we got them in
so
joining me to help answer these
questions we've got xbox expert jordan
remake
what's up and playstation pro tumor
hussein
absolutely ready to be engorged on these
consoles lads
what do you mean like you'd be engorged
because you've eaten too much
don't ask ask a follow-up question
questions
what's wrong with you how many times
have we done this
too many all right let's get into it
all right first question coming from ty
crowe tc without the stand
does the console wiggle around while
sitting so if you're having it
vertically
technically you could have it without
the stand but i wouldn't recommend it
the stand kind of gives it extra
purchase
also it screws into place so it feels
way more secure if you have to stand
when it's vertical
if you're having it horizontal you won't
be able to use it without the stand
especially if it's the disc version
which is the one that we have
the because it's not flat on either side
it obviously has those curves
um it's very easy to like
unbalance it and so obviously that's not
something you want to have if you've got
a disc in there
so use the stand one thing i'll say
about the stand is that like i said on
the bottom it screws in
which is super useful but on the side it
just kind of like
perches over the edge and it doesn't
have a click or any kind of
feedback that tells you that it's really
snugly on there and so one bit of advice
i'll also give
is that the stand obviously has rubber
soles on the bottom
great beatles album but like rubber sole
if you turn it like if you
i don't know moving it to try and get
the cables in around the back
it comes off very easily so be warned
yeah my recommendation is if you can not
everyone is a capable of it but like
vertical is the way to go it feels
stable and i feel like of the two
uh orientations vertical looks better as
well to me
um and if you get like the the sony
pulse headset you can also kind of use
it as a
a kind of like place to leave as you can
see that i'm doing here
like i've got my uh headset just like
resting on top of the console and it
works really nicely
um and then i just take it off when i
need it and it feels way more stable
when it's vertical than it is i
initially had it horizontal and i was
like i don't like this
i put it vertical it definitely looks
very aesthetically pleasing
yeah for sure and also because of the
way the vents are
i feel like for some reason i feel like
i'm giving it a better chance of staying
cool vertical
um just because of the way it pushes the
air out um
and when it's horizontal i don't know
for some reason i feel like the fans are
quite like
they're not getting as much to work with
in terms of space
the surface area feels a little more
like compact and tightened
and that's just like brain my brain
reading in like that but
i i would recommend vertical over
horizontal all right next question from
i'm sorry if i butcher this but a queal
month as
i think that's akiel akil early
impressions on the dual sense controller
here it is um so
there is a lot to like about the
dualsense controller honestly i mean
elite series 2 is my
favorite controller and this one
i i would say like
it's not as heavy as the elite series 2
it's heavier than the dual shock
and it has it's bigger so it like feels
better in your hands
dual shark 4 for me like i have very bad
repetitive strain injury in this arm and
like i can't play
some games for a long long period of
time like i was playing persona 5
royal the other day and i was literally
playing left-handed just like
working my way through because i just
couldn't hold on for too long whereas
i did like a couple of really long
gaming stretches on the dual sense at
the weekend and it felt really great
like it felt way more ergonomic for me
um the haptic feedback and adaptive
triggers are super cool and so
astrobot comes pre-loaded on the console
and honestly that is a really cool
whistle stop tour of how
all the functionality in the dual sense
works there's really cool bits like
where astro bot is
uh like in this spring-loaded suit
and you have to hold the trigger at
different strengths to like
get a different height of your jump
which is really cool um
it's super responsive i like that the
buttons are a little softer to press on
the
on the face triggers feel uh sorry the
thumbsticks feel pretty similar
just like it's a really nice controller
and i think the haptic feedback works
super super well
astro bot is yeah like i said the the
showcase for that
yeah i think in terms of like lucy said
it's a bit heavier than the dual shock
for
um it feels good though uh
the one thing that has taken me some
getting used to is
the bottom of the actual um controller
where it used to have rounded edges is
now tapered off
um and i'm used to like resting like the
bottom of my palms in that and now it's
like it feels like
it kind of like it's harder to do that
it kind of like presses down which is
like it's easy to get used to it
but um it's just a bit unexpected um the
buttons
feel slightly more clicky but not in an
unsatisfying way
um the yeah and the other thing is like
the the home button
is no longer a circular button it's just
it's
it's it's molded after the playstation
symbol
so if you're used to likes like uh
elegantly moving your finger over
to like to to hit the button you might
it might take some getting used to to
like instead feel the playstation symbol
otherwise it's it's pretty a pretty good
controller i've found
aesthetically it's really nice as well
the white
um does require a little bit of
maintenance i found but we'll come to
that later
yeah i mean honestly the white looks a
little more gray to me doesn't look as
stark as i think all the marketing stuff
would suggest
um also it also has a mute button
because the microphone there is a
microphone built in to the dual sense
and it has a little mute button on it so
you can just be like oh
no i'm not talking to you today but it's
a nice controller i like it
diego coming in with a little bit of uh
investigative
journalism it seems that the hdmi cable
included
in the ps5 box is an high speed hdmi
and not an ultra high speed which would
mean that it's 2.0 and not
2.1 can you look can you please look
into this
i'm gonna lay out the facts as i know
them yet because we're still waiting on
sony to confirm
that hdmi i don't personally have the
ability to test this
at home i don't think tam does either on
the xbox series x
box it says ultra high speed hdmi
on the xbox series s box it says
high speed hdmi on the playstation 5 box
it says high speed hdmi so
that's what we know so far we're waiting
on confirmation
it leads me to believe that it's a 2.0
based solely on wording but i don't have
an 8k
output that i can test it on so
we're waiting for our tech boys and sony
to confirm that yeah
i say now that you put that out into the
world thanks to the luck of this show
sony's definitely oh it's gonna get
announced
between wednesday they're gonna be like
there's actually there's actually a
little white sticker next to the word hi
if you peel it off it says ultra yeah
surprise
so so that's what we know so far i just
don't want to have any misinformation
out there i'm not going to outright say
it is or it isn't that's just what my
conclusions lead me to believe but
yeah happy to be wrong and grow from the
experience you know
no i hate being no no coming from
chris kelly films absolutely sizzling oh
my god i hate
that has influenced the questions
absolutely sizzling for some ps5 info i
would like to know about the psvr camera
adapter
and if it's included in the box it is
not included
in the box my friend however you can
request your playstation vr camera
adapter by going to camera hyphen
adapter.support.playstation.com
forward slash en um
i'm glad i got that in one take um yes
so uh yeah so you'll need that adapter
um you can go there i believe it's free
um and then i think it requires a serial
number from you
um to to get the actual uh adapter sent
out to you
but yeah i think it makes a lot of sense
that they didn't just
include it in in the box i know people
are like why didn't you just conclude it
it's because
it is an expense to manufacture pack in
and distribute and there's no guarantee
that literally everyone who has a plate
or bought a playstation vr
will want it and there's no reason to
include it and assume that everyone has
one i was gonna say like
compared to how many psvr units are sold
definitely hit a million maybe closer to
two i'm not sure of the
most recent sales figures compared to
i don't know you're looking at over 100
million ps4s sold
don't know how many they've done in
pre-orders for ps5 but it's yeah it's
just not economical to put it in every
box
it could have been a lot of like wasted
space and redundant like uh inclusion in
if like a lot of people didn't have it
yeah they probably would have had to
charge more
they saw what happened with the xbox one
and connect they didn't want to do that
basically they were like if you care
enough tell us and we'll send you one
for free
coming in from downtown griffin brown
game spot do your hands sweat quickly
while holding the dual sense or does it
take a while for your hands to sweat
while holding it or
not at all just asking because i have
very sweaty hands and want to know what
to expect
sweaty hand gang let's go um i was
i was kind of leaving the pause there
because i wasn't sure who was gonna
so i i i will i don't have like
extra extraordinarily sweaty hands but i
do like
i'm a gamer you know i hit buttons
really quickly i've got a lot of aps i'm
a gamer you know what i'm saying like
i'm
hitting headshots landing dragon punches
doing one frame links
i'm you know all right i can't tell if
any of that was
apex apex gamer here so my hands tend to
get sweaty
um it the dual sense
doesn't like i i can't measure is there
an accurate way to
measure how a piece of technology draws
there are like hydrosis i think that's
what it's called hydrosis sensors that
they measure in
psychometric testing don't have one of
those but i will say
um it doesn't get i don't think my hand
sweats any more than it would with any
other controller
the difference with this one is the
texture of the dual sense is
it's like a matted textured finish um
unlike the more glossy sleek slicker
dual shock um so what tends to happen is
like you can
feel it more instead of like it being
you know
feeling like you know your hands is warm
or whatever and
if you are a very very sweaty hand
person you might notice that the
dual sense coloration changes quite
quickly you might if you take a close
look at it you might see some grime
as you might have seen earlier um on hit
video game website gamespot.com
the actual texture of the back of the
dual sense is made up of
thousands of tiny playstation symbols
squares what is it
what a talented photographer who must
have got that shot
yeah who was it who had to be walked
through it over soon
so yeah you can see that picture that
lucy took there but like those
playstation symbols are trapping some of
your hand grime baby
i'm at the stage now i don't know where
you can see it so i have had this mouse
for like
four years and it's at the point where
i'm getting some
mad grime eat the grime no
but like this is this is a black
mouse and like oh my god there's like
what's the mouse equivalent of an arse
groove on a couch
because i've got it
uh yeah so because of the textured
finish one you'll probably
notice that you're sweating a bit more
too you might find that
the coloration is like the controller is
holding grime a bit more i did notice
after a long
session of gaming because i'm a gamer
you know i play in long sessions
um i i looked at my controller and it
was like slightly grayed
um but like i just wiped it off and it
was fine and um
all the sony then to lead with demon
souls as the
launch title for a playstation um
but yeah that's that's that's my that
has been your sweat minute
damn never never thought i'd be friends
with a gamer
speaking of dual sense coming from
slayer does the dual sense haptic
feedback feel like the hd rumble on the
switch
or is it completely different if so is
it better or worse than hd rumble
god it's so much better than hd
hd rumble is um
uh how would you describe it like during
that pause
i just imagine miyamoto's head slowly
turning to look in your direction
yeah what hd rumble
is um not
delicate let's put it that way yeah it's
very like
ah it's vibrating you hit something
i think what the joseon also has going
for it is
it's not just the rumble and the
vibration
it works really well with the triggers
um
which you know they can they can
manually adjust the tension on triggers
so when that's combined with like subtle
vibrational movements in the controller
it leads for a more like immersive and
different experience it genuinely feels
like unique and new in the way that
they're doing it
it's like surprisingly exciting as a
feature i hope that more people
more developers use it it did remind me
of the sensation
you get when you got the original like
xbox
controller and were playing uh one xbox
one controller and were playing
like forza and you could feel like when
you're going on different terrains
while driving and it feels like that
like cranked up to 11 and you can like
when you run on certain surfaces you can
feel the change in the vibration
and you know certain behaviors will have
different uh
feel to it which is good yeah there's
been a bunch of stuff that developers
have said in like blog posts about
you know the devs behind ghost why tokyo
and
um obviously miles morales um ratchet
and clang they're all saying
the different ways that they're using
the dual sense so i definitely think in
this first wave this first
push of ps5 titles that developers will
be utilizing it and i just really hope
it continues because it's it's really
cool like it's
yeah there's bits in astrobot where
you're like gliding on ice and it feels
really different you're just walking on
like oh yeah because you go from sand
to walking on ice and like it feels
different even just
walking so it's super cool it'll be cool
to see how third-party studios
handle all of those features because we
only hear about it right now with all of
sony's first party studios
in their games yeah there's there's
certain games that we've seen already
like for example demon souls we saw
like the the weird repost new repost
animation where
the character lifts the enemy up into
the air and like slams him to the ground
and i bet
blue point are all over that with like
rumble and
they're gonna be in there god they'd be
so cool coming in with the
last question chris tiaghi asks
do you need a new tv to support the hdmi
2.1
given with the ps5 an hdmi 2.1 cable
is an hdmi cable like it doesn't matter
if you don't have an 8k
or uh tv like you'll be able to use a
2.1 cable
as your hdmi cable so
until we've got clarification on whether
or not it is a 2.1 in the ps5
you don't need a new tv unless you want
to
play stuff at 8k which
i don't think who's doing all that yeah
it's it's really not worth buying an 8k
yeah if you're thinking about buying an
aktv
unless you are a millionaire and really
have no worries about your finances
i wouldn't recommend it i can't even
think of a game that's coming out that
supports
8k yeah maybe there's one and i'm just
dumb and can't think of it but
yeah if you're buying an aktv you're
doing it flex
in which case more power to you so those
are the questions that we can answer
at this moment in time uh we'll
obviously be able to talk more about the
console
over the coming weeks so if you've got
more questions for about the playstation
5
for us uh leave them in the comments or
tweet them at us
or we'll probably do another youtube
community post um
there is other playstation 5 stuff going
on
this week and xbox stuff too don't worry
we're not forgetting about the xbox
so tam do you want to talk about
playstation stuff happening uh that
should be live by the time this goes out
yeah so in terms of playstation stuff
the big one is uh
that we have a demon souls uh interview
which is going to be live on site as a
written piece
but you can also watch the interview and
fall on site as well
and then we've got a kind of condensed
version of it which breaks down
everything that
fans and people interested in the game
need to know about it
before it comes out i did the interview
myself
and so i asked a bunch of quite specific
questions that have been
plaguing my mind and i got a few good
answers so if you're interested in the
game check out that video there's some
good stuff in there good content in
there
and read it on the website as well and
in terms of xbox
huge news this week we've got the
unboxings in for the series s and series
x um as well as all that stuff about
backwards compatibility which is really
cool and now that we can start testing
on the series s which is awesome
we're all working on stuff coming out
for sirius x and playstation 5 that we
can't
really talk about if this is the second
to last episode of gen next to come out
before
the next gen consoles come out so like
we're all working on stuff we just
can't talk about everything that we're
working on
we've signed legal documents
phil spencer is just hanging out outside
my apartment going i dare you to make a
mistake
just shoot hey yoshida handing him a
clip like i'm here
you thought that team up at the game
awards
[Laughter]
it was for show anyway
thank you for watching uh remember put
your questions in for the playstation 5
and we'll see you next week
see ya for the playstation 5. it's not
like we're going to ask it like
hey how do you feel
i'm good lucy
was that goofy no that was like a goofy
mix with mickey
time do you want to talk about
playstation stuff happening uh that
should be live by the time this goes out
i have no idea what you're talking about
demon souls mate
[Laughter]
did i mention that i've not had any
sleep
i was about to say tam you are doing the
place to
stop doing it i could literally forgot
[Laughter]
that
your outro